la première apparition du sida c'était
il ya 25 ans et depuis la pandémie n'a
cessé de s'étendre 25 millions de
malades en sont morts et aujourd'hui il
y aurait dans le monde plus de 38
millions de personnes séropositives à
toronto au canada les spécialistes de la
maladie veulent convaincre les autorités
d'accroître les financements
céline liégeois toutes les six secondes
quelque part dans le monde
quelqu'un contractent le vih à ce jour
39 millions de personnes sont
contaminées
l'épidémie semble stabilisée la zone la
plus touchée l'afrique subsaharienne
près de 25 millions de séropositifs en
asie plus de 8 millions de personnes
sont contaminées amérique latine les
pays de l'ex urss
un million et demi environ c'est nouveau
l'inde est le pays qui compte le plus de
séropositifs devant l'afrique du sud
grâce notamment aux médicaments
génériques y ait des traitements
simplifier un million trois cent mille
personnes des pays pauvres ont accès aux
trithérapies c'est loin de l'objectif de
nos aînés qui visait les 3 millions il
est vrai que le coût des médicaments les
conflits et les tabous culturels ou
religieux freine la prévention et les
traitements reste la france
cent trente mille c'est l'estimation du
nombre de séropositifs
chaque année quelques 7000 personnes
contractent le vih le plus souvent lors
de rapports hétérosexuels
les femmes représentent plus de la
moitié des contaminations et parmi elles
ce sont les femmes immigrées qui sont
les plus touchés